SPEAKER: Let's get
started with Coursera.
The architecting with
Google Cloud Platform
specialization on Coursera
comprises six courses as shown.
When your email
address has been added,
you will get an
invitation email.
To start learning on Coursera,
open the Google Cloud Coursera
invitation email.
The email has the subject
line, "Join the Associate Cloud
engineer track offered
by Google Cloud."
In the email, click "Join Now"
to join the Associate Cloud
engineer track.
You will then create or sign
into your Coursera account
and agree to join the program.
Enroll in the first course,
Google Cloud Platform
Fundamentals core
infrastructure.
Courses have videos, hands
on Qwiklabs, and quizzes.
The courses provide an in-depth
explanation of key concepts
through videos.
You then learn to apply
the concepts by practicing
with hands on labs.
Here's my colleague
Philip Meyer giving you
an overview of Qwiklabs.
PHILIPP MAIER:
Hello, and welcome.
I'm Philipp Maier, a course
developer with Google Cloud
Platform.
And this is a brief tutorial on
using Qwiklabs in this course.
I'm about to show you
the interactive hands
on labs platform
called Qwiklabs,
which is part of Google Cloud.
Qwiklabs allows you to get
practical hands on experience
with GCP and provisions you
with Google account credentials
so you can access a
GCP console at no cost.
The first step is
to log into Coursera
in an incognito window.
Depending on your
browser, it may also
be called private browsing
or InPrivate browsing.
Logging into Coursera
from a private window
ensures that you
don't accidentally
use your own Google account
while accessing the Google
Cloud console.
We don't want you to
get any unexpected bills
at the end of the month.
Check out the links below this
video for different browser
support articles.
Once logged into Coursera
using an incognito window,
return to your course and
go to the lab activity page.
So if prompted, you want
to accept the honor code,
and you might even have
to enter your name.
Then you want to click
the "open tool" button
to open the lab in a new tab.
So within the new tab, you
can now click "start lab,"
and you want to wait until the
"lab running" is displayed.
For each lab you will have
a timer in the top right
with the remaining access time.
Your lab will automatically
end when the timer runs out.
On the left, you have
the connections detail.
Click "open Google
console," and then
sign in with the username
and password provided
in the connections detail pane.
So I'm going to copy the
username, paste that in here.
I'm also going to take the
password, paste it in here too.
Now Qwiklabs creates a new
account for you each time
you launch a lab.
Therefore you need to click
through the initial account set
up windows.
So essentially any
to accept this.
I don't need to add any
recovery phone number,
so I can just click done.
I'm going to agree to
the terms and services,
and I don't need any emails.
Now I can verify that I'm
using the Qwiklabs provided
account and project
within the GCB console.
So up here I see the
project ID, and over here I
can see the username.
And these are the
same ones that I
was provided with in the
connections detail pane.
You can also see that the
timer is still running.
Now some labs track you work
within the Qwiklabs provided
GCP project.
If this is enabled,
you'll see a score
in the top right
corner of the window,
as you can see right here.
Your score increases
as objectives are met,
and you can click on the score
to view the individual steps
to be scored.
Now that I've
completed the lab, I
can see my score
has been updated,
and I'm ready to
click "end lab."
Once I click "end
lab," the Qwiklabs
provided project and any
resources within that project
will be deleted.
I can close a Qwiklabs
lab page, and my grade
will be updated with my
lab score in Coursera.
That's it for this tutorial.
Remember to launch Coursera
in an incognito window
and use the Qwiklabs
provided credentials
to sign into the GCP console.
Good luck with the labs, and
enjoy the rest of this course.
SPEAKER: To summarize, complete
the architecting with Google
Cloud Platform
specialization on Coursera,
practice with hands
on labs on Qwiklabs,
and review related
product documentation.